[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur marc philippe
daubresse
madame la ministre du logement
après la funeste loi remet allures de
madame duflot qui a brisé la confiance
dans tous les milieux de l'immobilier de
la vie tant vous nous présenter en
deuxième lecture cet après-midi un volet
de la loi égalité citoyenneté funes
également puisqu'il est empreint de la
même idéologie
bureaucratique planificatrice est
dirigiste homme
monsieur hollande le président de la
république avait s'était engagé à
construire 500 mille logements neufs par
an
si je prends les statistiques de 2014 et
15 vous êtes en moyenne à 3 140 milles
je vous rappelle que du temps où
monsieur borloo monsieur chirac puis
monsieur sarkozy et monsieur fillon qui
ont assuré le financement de ce
programme ont fait leur programme nous
avions atteint 460 milles monsieur
hollande a réussi à inverser la courbe
mais pas dans le bon sens nous avions
nous avions triplé le financement du
logement social quadruplé l'accession à
la propriété
nous avions eu doubler le financement du
logement très social on en est loin
aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes toujours
dans cette logique coercitives et
dirigiste vous voulez réformer la loi
sru avec une vision de la politique du
peuple le mans qui est de dire si les
maires ne le font pas le préfet prendra
le relais et on va imposer aux maires à
cerdan de choses tout devrait être
fondée sur la diversité du territoire
sur la confiance sur le contrat avec les
maires qui parfois n'ont même pas la
compétence urbanisme ni les terrains
pour construire les logements que vous
leur demandez en plus vous faites
abstraction du logement locatif privé
alors que les plus pauvres de notre pays
sont dans le parc locatif privé ma
question est donc çà et là vous allez
changer de logiciel est ce que vous
allez essayer de faire les choses sur la
confiance comme françois fillon le
propose dans son programme cohérent et
courageux
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame emmanuelle cosse
ministre du logement et de l'habitat
durable
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député si votre bilan avait été aussi
bons en matière de logement je crois que
nous n'aurions pas à faire autant depuis
2012 en matière de logement vous voulez
des chiffres j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
les donner la semaine dernière et c'est
un plaisir de vous les redonner cette
année
435000 autorisations données sur les
douze derniers mois
367 huile pop on loge chantiers lancés
cent quarante mille logements sociaux
autorisés sur 2016 les meilleurs
chiffres depuis sept ans monsieur
daubresse depuis sept ans et nous allons
continuer et nous allons continuer
notamment la loi sru dont vous parlez 16
ans d'application est il normal qu'au
bout de 16 ans d'application il y ait
encore des mères qui refusent
d'appliquer cette loi et qui fasse
campagne électorale sur le sujet est il
normal quand il ya deux millions de
demandeurs de logement social que des
mercer morts portent à leur territoire
car ils ne veulent pas accueillir les
65% des français qui ont droit au
logement social je ne crois pas que
c'est normal le gouvernement ne le crois
pas et oui nous allons lutter contre les
ghettos nous imposons aux la loi égalité
citoyenneté de la mixité sociale
nous voulons mettre du rééquilibrage
dans les territoires et nous le faisons
avec beaucoup d'élus qui nous
soutiennent dans ce sujet et je vais
vous dire en 2013
la loi sur la mobilisation du foncier
public à autoriser les préfets à prendre
les permis de construire à la place des
mères qui ne voulaient pas construire et
nous le faisons aujourd'hui nous avons
plusieurs milliers de logements sociaux
qui sont construits grâce à ce
dispositif et nous allons continuer car
il n'est pas normal que certains
territoires se met en dehors de
l'égalité territoriale et du combat de
la mixité sociale voilà notre engagement
nous allons le poursuivre et et nous
allons continuer monsieur daubresse avec
les très bons résultats que nous avons
aujourd'hui
merci madame la ministre